well as a numbers guy objectively
um even if these studios are having a
rough go in terms of their stock price
like that they they can afford uh to
compensate Folks at higher levels I mean
that that's objective well some of their
executives are making a lot of money
yeah yeah I mean and some of these
companies now have had massive run-ups
even Netflix which I just described I
mean you know they're still in the
hundreds of billions of dollars in terms
of uh values evaluation uh which uh you
know now it's a little bit lower than it
was you know like 18 months ago but
um but it's still plenty in the scheme
of things so who is on the other side of
this negotiation when you think of
Studios uh is it uh and how does that
negotiation work on their side well so
I'm not in those into Oceanic committees
I just know what I what I know from the
outside but the studios they band
together under an umbrella that they
call the alliance of motion picture and
television producers the amptp and so
these are ordinarily they're competitors
any other time of the year they're
always trying to take market share away
from each other but every three years
they they band together to negotiate as
one because it gives them strength uh
and so that's what we're negotiating
against and was it the case that one
reason the writers strike uh ended last
time was like one of the studios came
forward and said okay we'll cut this
deal yes that's what that's how you uh
because you know the guild were I think
9 000 writers so how do you possibly
stand up against these multinational
conglomerates like it's they're so big
and strong and we're just a handful of
writers and so the tactic last time uh
was that you really just get them to
turn against each other because they're
natural they're natural competitors
they're little Game of Thrones action
yeah they don't I don't like they're not
best friends and so when you're when the
strike is happening they don't they
can't make content they're just sitting
on their hands watching their stock
prices go through the floor and they can
claim they have a different business
model but no their the business model is
manual is producing and selling
television shows across the world and so
the last strike uh one of them stepped
forward it was United Artist I think was
the first one that stayed after like two
or two months of the strike they came to
the writer school and said okay let's
let's Hammer this out and make a deal an
interim deal and they proposed terms
that were much more favorable to the
writers with the condition that once the
final deal was settled that's the deal
they would take but then they had a
competitive advantage over the other
Studios because now they're back in the
business of making TV shows and and
movies and so that's how you do it you
turn them against each other
wow who's the weak link this time who's
the United Artist in 2023 yeah United
Artists and then or maybe Letterman
maybe worldwide pants may have been
first I don't remember and then also
Lionsgate they were among the first two
to uh you know to drop it and then it's
like dominoes because now they have an
advantage over the others because you
know they want to make TV shows it is
like the herd man you got to pick the
weakest one yeah like the the one that
that really desperately wants
um to steal a march on the others so
just look up the studios by market cap
find the lowest one and then everyone
shows up the door and be like hey we got
a bunch of writers here we go
but you know at the end of the day it's
like
I I see where they're coming from I
don't hate them they're prioritizing
their job which is maximize profits and
they're not looking after me that's not
their job I don't expect them to so the
writers have to look after ourselves and
at the end of the day we want we want
the same thing that they want which is
they want to make boatloads of money and
we want to be the people who make them
that boatloads of money right that's it
we just want to be able to afford to be
able to do that
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guests thank you